# China, Hong Kong & Macau, Oh My!
Welcome to Hong Kong: the island city of China
packed with seven million people at unbelievable
density.
But if you, dear tourist, start from Victoria
Harbor and head toward the mainland you'll
find that while Hong Kong is China she doesn't
act like it.
To cross the bridge your passport must be
checked and stamped and checked and stamped.
Not because you're a suspicious foreigner:
Mainland Chinese can't just stroll across
either, but rather because Hong Kong has her
own immigration policy.
And Hong Kong isn't the only isolated island,
there's nearby Macau with her own passport-checking
bridge and a ferry between them -- which also
checks passports.
Travel from Hong Kong to Macau to the mainland
and back and you'll end up with three stamps,
and that goes for everyone: Hong Kongese can't
just live in Macau and Macanese can't just
live in Hong Kong and they both can just live
on the mainland.
Yet it's all China.
And inconvenient travel isn't the only speciality
of these sister islands.
They also have:
* Separate governments and political parties.
* Separate police.
* Separate money.
* Postal systems.
* Schools.
* and languages.
Hong Kong even has her own Olympic team which
competed in the 2008 *Beijing* olympics which
doesn't make any kind of sense.
The only things these sister islands don't
have that other countries do:
1) Their own armies.
Though that isn't unique with modern countries,
and…
2) Formal diplomatic relations.
Though even this unclear as both are members
of international trade organizations.
And other countries have 'embassies' in Hong
Kong and Macau, sure China won't let them
be called embassies, those are only for **mighty
Beijing** -- they're called *consulates* even
if they're bigger than Beijing's embassy.
All this makes Hong Kong and Macau, as mentioned
in a previous video, the most country-like
countries that aren't countries.
So why are they China?
China says so.
It's called 'One China, Two Systems' -- though
fast-counters in the audience will see it
should be called 'One China, *Three* Systems.
Also there's China's special economic zones
(where capitalism runs free) making it more
like 'One China *Four* Systems' -- and if
China got her way it might be 'One China,
*Five* Systems'.
But we can't talk about everything so back
to China, Hong Kong, and Macau (oh my!)
China ended up having these two essentialy
city-states, as always, because Empire.
Portugal showed up in Asia in the 1500s and
didn't exactly make friends.
China and Portugal skirmished until Portugal
used Bigger-pile-of-money diplomacy to bribe
a local Chinese official into turning over
the islands of Macau as a trading port.
Later, Britannia found China and discovered
she had many of lovely things like silks and
porcelain and precious, precious tea that
Britannia craved.
In return China wanted from Britannia… to
be left alone and Britannia nobly agreed to
respect China's independence and soverenty.
OOPS!
OPIUM WARS!
Nothing generates demand like addiction -- which
Britannia was happy to supply.
And, her bigger-gun diplomacy secured Hong
Kong as a base through which the drugs must
flow.
Later in a world where telegraphs and lightbulbs
were newfangled a lease gave control of Hong
Kong to Britannia for 99 years or quote "as
good as forever", kicking the transfer problem
down the generations to be delt with by the
unimaginably futuristic society of the 1990s.
Thus these sister cities grow up under the
influence of their Emperiffic parents.
Hong Kong had English common law and lived
in Britannia's org chart as one of her many
crown colonies and Macau had Portuguese civil
law.
And the parental effect is still seen today:
visit Hong Kong and she is clearly Britannia's
daughter what with her love of business and
international finance (and lasers!) and english-accented
language and near-identical transport system.
Macau had a more troubled adolescence, as
her bigger sister stole the spotlight with
her trading skills.
But Macau eventually grew up to be the gambling
capital of the world.
She's Las Vegas x10 with a mixture of Portugal
and China.
But Empires come and empires go, and the 90s
eventually arrived, meaning Britannia's lease
expired.
Portugal claimed the treaty gave her control
of Macau *forever* but China disagreed and
the UN was in a no-empires-no-longer mood,
and frankly had Portugal complained too much,
China could have used her own bigger-army
diplomacy at this point to resolve the situation.
So the transfer was going to happen: but the
world was nervous about China, what with the
*lingering communism* and all, so the deal
was the Empire's daughters would go *but*
they had to remain basically independent,
to which China agreed as long as everyone
else agreed to call them China.
The situation was a bit like if the US had
to give Alaska back to Russia and Russia *super*
promised to leave Alaska self-governing.
You couldn't blame the locals for being nervous.
But, unlike what you'd expect in this case
China has mostly left the little sister islands
alone.
So everything is dandy...
*however*...
The handover came with its own version of
the as-good-as-forever clause.
China didn't agree to leave Hong Kong and
Macau alone *for all time*, only fifty years,
again passing political problems to a future
generation.
(Hopefully one that's actually unimaginably
futuristic this time).
Anyway, assuming such provincial concerns
as these are not rendered irrelevant by the
singularity, what happens in the 2040s?
Will Hong Kong and Macau remain tiny city-states
or will they lose their independence and be
absorbed?
Only China knows, and China does not say.